hello
i'm david karen from the department of
pathology at the university of michigan
and today i'm going to be discussing the
newest methods to detect monoclonal
proteins these are known as m proteins
and proteins are immunoglobulin products
secreted by plasma cell tumors
the methods we're going to talk about
today include capillary electrophoresis
serum free light chain measurements
and heavy light chain measurements
i have some disclosures to make
i get some financial support from
sebia
i consult for them and i give lectures
for them
i'm also a trustee of the american board
of pathology
and i receive royalties for a book i
write on protein electrophoresis that is
published by the american society for
clinical pathology press
during this session i'd like you to
please enter your questions while i'm
giving the presentation but unless
something looks urgent to me i'm going
to probably answer them all at the end
after this lecture my objectives are
that you will be able to implement a
process for detecting m proteins
that you'll understand the value and the
challenges of immunofixation and
immunosubtraction techniques
that you'll be able to recognize several
causes of false positive and false
negative tests by these
methods and that you'll understand the
value
and concerns
about
both the serum free light chain test
and the rather new heavy light chain
test
so
what are monoclonal democracies
these are disorders that are caused by
clonal proliferations of plasma cells
and by their products
these products
turned m proteins are immunoglobulins
that are produced by the plasma cell
clones
the detection of such products helps in
the initial diagnosis
the stratification of the risk that
these processes progress to a malignancy
and in following their response to
therapy
some of these diseases such as multiple
myeloma
are mainly due to the
large tumor burden
others such as al amyloid and the others
that i've listed here may have lower
tumor burdens but cause damage to many
tissues
due to the altered forms of the
monoclonal immunoglobulin product
termed amyloid
finally
some of the conditions are classified as
premalignant they all have the potential
to progress to multiple myeloma and
other malignant disorders
but at the present time they would be
asymptomatic
these would be
monoclonal gammopathy of undetermined
significance a mouthful of a term that
we abbreviate as mgus
and
smoldering or atypical multiple myeloma
multiple myeloma is the most malignant
of these conditions
it's relatively common
and it accounts for about 10 percent of
hemologic malignancies across the united
states
now while this condition usually occurs
in older individuals
it can be found in individuals under the
age of 40.
the m protein that we detect in multiple
myeloma was in fact the very first
measurable tumor marker discovered over
150 years ago
the incidence of multiple myeloma varies
depending on gender with men having a
higher incidence than women
and also by race with blacks having a
higher rate than whites or hispanics
and asians having the lowest overall
rate
the fact
that there is differences based upon
race and gender along with
family familial occurrence of the
disease implies that there is a genetic
component to multiple myeloma
now all the methods that i'm presenting
this morning are robust
false negatives can occur
because while m proteins usually migrate
in the gamma region of electrophoretic
gels as i'll show you in a minute
they can migrate in the alpha or beta
regions when they do this
their presence
can be obscured by some of the normal
serum proteins that i've listed here
in this session i'll show you ways that
we can detect these obscured m proteins
by looking for suspicious findings
on the electrophoretic patterns
in addition to the false magnets we can
have false positives when other serum
proteins like fibrinogen are present
with capillary electrophoresis
techniques
radio contrast dyes and some drugs
especially
antibiotics can give suspicious bands
the serum free light chain test is
performed
by a technique called nephelometry
free light chains
used to be detected mainly by doing a
urine immunofixation i've abbreviated
here by ife
however that tech test requires urine
and often all we receive are serum
samples
but recently
the serum free light chain
test has been developed as a
methylometric essay by bradwell and
colleagues i'll go over this test in
some detail it is a very handy test
however
it is subject to a problem called the
high dose hook effect also known as
antigen except excess effect and i'll
show you an example of that
even with that problem however free
light chain test is a very important
tool
especially for looking at
the unusual case of
illegal secretory on non-secretory
multiple myeloma
let's look at the types of m-protein
products that we're looking for
this data
is from a classic study performed by
kyle and colleagues at the mayo clinic
they reported that the majority of newly
diagnosed cases of multiple myeloma
secrete igg
about 20 of them make iga but you'll
notice in the green
piece of the pie
about 20 percent of cases make only the
very small
free life chain molecules of kappa and
lambda and that's important because
those cases are hard to detect by just
looking at serum protein electrophoresis
because these precap and lambda chains
are so small they readily pass into the
urine and can be detected there by urine
immuno fixation
however the serum free ly chain test
that i'll describe in a moment is an
effective means to detect these
molecules by automated methylometry and
serum
igm proteins are usually not secreted in
multiple myeloma they're found in a
condition called waldenstrom
macroglobulin anemia that we're not
going to be discussing today
other components such as igd bipolar ige
are rare
serum and protein
electrophoresis can be performed by
either gel methods
where samples of serum or urine are acid
on a solid surface or by capillary zone
electrophoresis which is a free flowing
system that i will show you in a moment
with gel techniques after we've
detected an m protein we want to
identify their isotype that is gam kappa
or lambda and we do that by
immunofixation
with capillary electrocreases
we identify them by a technique called
immunosubtraction that i'll show you now
when urine protein electrophoresis is
used
fixation is usually used to identify
them
gel electrophoresis is usually performed
on agarose gels these days
at an alkaline buffer ph of 8.6
at that ph
all serum proteins are negatively
charged
therefore they're attracted to the
positively charged anode
however the gel itself has a net
negative charge
such that the positively charged ions in
the buffer migrate toward cathode this
creates a stream of movement toward the
cathode called end osmotic flow
now because of this flow of buffer ions
the weakly anionic gamma globulins end
up being pulled toward the cathode note
that they're on the cathode side of the
origin
normal serum has the major protein shown
in this cartoon albumin
toward the anode and is the large band
alpha-1 globulin alpha-2 globulin
beta 1-globulin beta-2 globulin and
gamma globulin
the amount of protein in each major band
is determined by making a densitometric
scan of the gel
and using a total protein measurement of
serum to identify
the quantity in each region
here are two samples of real cases
on the top we see a normal sample
note in the gamma region toward the
right is quite smooth and very broad
staining with a think blue
below it
is a case from a patient who has
multiple myeloma
note that in the middle of the gamma
region there is a very dense band this
is the immunoglobulin product of those
plasma cells in the m protein
when performing gel based techniques one
has a variety of products to choose from
i prefer
using a gel that provides a crisp
separation of the two beta region bands
beta 1 as i show here is transferring
the second beta region band is the third
component of complement
c3
as you can see
as we move down the scale toward poorer
resolution from different products
the distinction of these two
bands becomes less reliable
i think this separation is important
because many m proteins will migrate in
the beta region especially iga m
proteins
with better resolution
one can be suspicious if there is a
distortion of one of those bands i'll
show you such a separation in just a
moment
with capillary electrophoresis there is
no solid support
the samples of serum are aspirated into
the anodic end of a thinly
a thin strongly negatively charged
silica capillary tube
because
of the negative charge
on its interior walls and its high ph
this is performed at ph 10.
a very strong end osmotic flow
pulls the proteins
past the detector
this detector measures
the absorbance of a 214 nanometer signal
this is used because this is the
wavelength at which peptide bonds
absorb
by identifying the protein
now after the proteins pass through this
their
bands are detected in a sample called
the electrophorogram
this is the resulting electroparagram on
a normal sample note the crisp
separation of transforming beta 1 and c3
beta 2 bands that i've indicated you can
also see many of the other bands
that are of importance
this is a serum
from a patient who has a large
monoclonal democracy but clinically this
patient was asymptomatic there was no
increase in calcium no anemia
no renal disease because there were no
clinical problems this patient was
classified as being one of the
pre-malignant conditions
monoclonal mammography of undetermined
significance and thus
there's a prominent m spike in the gamma
region and i've colored it for you in
pink
and this is how we measure the sample
in this case you may see at the bottom
it measures 2.2
grams per deciliter now the larger
the m spike is in patients with mgus the
high the higher is their likelihood of
progressing to a malignant condition
relatively soon such as multiple myeloma
after detecting
and measuring the m protein it's
important to determine if the m protein
is igg iga
igm or rarely igd or
ige
patients with an igg mgus
are less likely to progress to multiple
myeloma
than those who have an iga invest
is also important when you follow the
patients
after therapy because the mgus
of the monoclonal democracy may
disappear
and then
with therapy sometimes you get the
production of smaller reactive bands
that could be confused if you didn't
identify the original isotope
we can characterize the m protein by
either immunofixation or
immunosubtraction immunofixation is used
on gels while immunosubtraction is used
in capillary electrophoresis
although immunofixation is more
sensitive and versatile because it does
pick up the rare ige and uncommon igb
cases i found immunosubtraction to be
useful in helping you to measure some m
proteins and i'll show you an example of
that during this talk
immunosubtraction also requires less
technologies time and is less likely to
be affected by a manual pipetting error
for immunofixation we apply the sample
to six lanes of an agulos gel
in this cartoon i'm putting the anode at
the top
we perform electrophoresis then to
separate the various proteins but none
is yet visible
then in lane one we fix the proteins in
place with an acid but the other to the
other lanes we apply a specific
antiserum against igg iga igm the most
common heavy chains found kappa and
lambda
we need light chains
we wash and stain and get a pattern that
looks like this
this shows a normal immuno fixation
note that normal igg is diffuse and
located in the gamma region while normal
iga is also diffuse but is located more
anodely toward the beta region
there's very little igm present in this
case and the kappa and lambda
which in this case are attached to igg
aorm
are both diffuse and mainly in the gamma
region keep these features in mind as we
look at the next case
here igg is still diffuse but a bit
darker this reflects the presence of
more protein
however
if you look at the iga lane
as the arrows show there is a distinct
band at the anodal end
a band with the identical migration as
the iga band is present in the kapolei
this identifies it as an iga kappa
m protein you can see it over in this
theorem protein electrophoresis spe lane
as well just a bit obscured by the
presence of other bands
for capillary electrophoresis there are
no proteins to fix in place because it's
a continuously flowing system
so i show you how we deal with this in
the following cartoon
on the top left in this cartoon i show
the
paragram
with the anode at the left
the pattern has a normal albumin that
indicated by the
purple band but a prominent spike is
present in the gamma region
i say that the spike is an igg kappa
so below this electroperogram i show how
the igg capper molecules might have
lined up as they passed by the detector
to identify the light chains in this
gamma spike
now to identify them
i used an antiserum against kappa anti k
i mix that with the serum and put it
through the capillary again
these antikepha immunoglobulins bind all
kaffir-containing molecules
this results in a very bulky antigen
antibody complex as i've indicated below
because of their bulk they migrate more
slowly through the capillary and are now
found in the albumin region
the image below shows that only lambda
containing molecules remain in the gamma
region as they pass by the detector
in effect if the m spike has been
immunosubtracted with antikappa letting
you know that catholic is a major
component of this spike
let's see how that works in practice
here's an actual immune of subtraction
it shows the original electrophoresis
pattern in the top left panel it
contains a prominent spike
in the beta region
in the top right panel the black line
indicates
the original position of the spike while
the blue lines show what happens after
treatment with antibodies igg
similar to the kappa in the cartoon the
igg containing molecules have been
immunosubtracted from the beta region
and moved toward albumin which i
indicate with the red arrow
in the middle two panels the results of
pre-treatment with
anti-iga on the left and anti-igm on the
right so that the blue spike remains
essentially unchanged
however comparing anti-kappa
on the bottom left panel
with anti-lambda on the bottom right
panel we see
that the
antikappa subtracts the spike
while the anti-lambda is not
this identifies the m spike as an igg
kappa m protein
some spikes that are due to small
molecules can readily be identified in
the urine and that's classically how
we've detected them for many years
while intact igg weighs about 160
kilojoules monoclonal free
catholic chains were only about 25
kilovolts and free lambda chains that
exist mainly as dimers were only about
50 kilo dollars
therefore
these three light chains readily pass
into the urine while igg does not
to detect free light chains
one can perform urine protein
electrophoresis on concentrated urine
here i show several samples of urine
some with moderate glomerular damage
permitting large amounts of albumin and
a few other proteins to pass into the
urine
in the third sample from the top
there is a minor tubular injury shown by
several lightly staining bands to the
right of aldebaran but there's also a
distinct spike indicated by the arrow in
the gamma region
this spike was a monopoly protein that
was characterized as kappa free light
chain by performing immunofixation
to measure it
the international myeloma working group
recommends that a 24-hour urine sample
is collected the total protein is
measured and the density metric scan as
shown here is performed to determine the
fraction of monochrome free light chain
here it was measured by densitometry
and found to contain
9636 grams in 24-hour period
with the 20 of cases that i showed you
earlier that are classified as light
chain myeloma this is the test that is
still recommended to follow patients
who are
on various chemotherapeutic regimens
normal plasma cells produce the heavy
chains gamma alpha and mu separately
from the light chains
when the light chains are produced in
excess
they pass into the serum
and are quickly excreted into the air
that's why urine protein electrophoresis
and immunofixation techniques have been
the standard for initial detection of
monochrome free light chains for many
years
however
three light chains do exist in the serum
and with a sensitive enough technique
one can measure free kappa and free
lambda chains in the serum that is the
importance of the new nephelometric
method to test for serum free light
change
however while this test is useful for
initial protection of monochrome 3 light
chain one still needs to collect 24-hour
urine afterwards to follow patients with
light chain myeloma
here's a brief summary of how antibodies
specific to serum tree light chains are
made
in the cartoon at the right
i show theoretical antigenic
determinants which i'll call epitopes on
the surface of the free light chain
a b c d e and f
i've labeled e and f
in red because they indicate epitopes
that are specific for free lychee
in the bottom right cartoon i show why
that cell
those are the epitopes that are specific
for free light chain molecules because
they're bound to the heavy chains
and are on the interior of the molecule
and not available to bind anti-free
catholic chains
bradwell and colleagues
took advantage
of this
fact to create antibodies in sheep
by specific immunization and extensive
absorption studies
this is important because
large molecules like igg which contain
two identical heavy chains and two light
chains either two identical kappa or two
identical lambda and a half life of
about three weeks
while light chains have a half-life of
only a couple of hours
consequently
the amount
of
light chains that are attached to heavy
chains in serum occur at about 1 000
times the concentration of the free
light chains
so after these specific antibodies were
created bradwell and colleagues
published
a key paper and here's data from their
original work
it graphs the free like chains
concentration on the x-axis the free
lambda like chain concentration on the
y-axis and these are log graphs as you
see
normal sera are shown in violet
individuals with renal disease are in
the turquoise fluid
individuals with renal disease
can't excrete the light changes readily
and have higher amounts of both pre
kappa and lambda in their serum however
the key is that the ratio of capital
lambda is normal
note the rectangular normal capital
lambda ratio box placed around these
samples
in contrast patients who have free kappa
myeloma have their results in the bottom
right as black squares none of these are
in the normal range for kappa and lambda
ratio
and those with free lambda myeloma have
their results separate as blue triangles
in the upper left
also shown on this slide are patients
who have a l amyloid these are shown in
white depending on and they are either
mostly above or below the normal
rectangle area
depending on whether they're kappa or
lambda however note it doesn't separate
all cases of al amyloid
much less tumor burden
much less
protein is made in many of these cases
and they cannot all be distinguished
even by this technique
a year after bradwell's initial paper
katzman and colleagues from the mayo
clinic showed that fight using a
diagnostic range that excluded all 282
reference samples that they used in
their study
they could improve the specificity from
the 95 confidence interval which would
be the 0.3 to 1.2
range
to
9 over 99
while retaining the sensitivity
of 99 plus percent
katzman did further studies to show
how effective this range would be in
picking up known cases of
free light chains that they would that
they had detected at the male clinic
then you looked at serum
from
428 patients who had known urinary m
proteins
detected initially by immuno fixation
and
capsule found
that they could detect
99.5 percent of these cases if serum
immuno fixation and serum free light
chain measurements were performed they
didn't need to use your urine at all and
they missed no cases of multiple myeloma
the only two cases that weren't picked
up for this one was a case that likely
was from a contamination and was a false
positive and the other case was a case
of m gus which is a benign which is a
non-malignant condition at the present
time although it can progress to a
morgan condition and just needs to be
followed
the international myeloma working group
has suggested guidelines for how to use
serum free live chain tests as i've just
shown you from the katzman data the
serum free light chain test can
substitute for urine in the initial
workup of patients suspected of
hybriding a monoclonal monopoly
secondly
the baseline measurement of the serum
free light chain test at the time of
initial detection provides useful
prognostic information for all plasma
cell disgraces myeloma
welding strains
or mdus
further
it is very useful to detect and follow
al amyloid
light chain deposition disease
lcdd
and oligosecretory myeloma a lego
secretory myeloma
implies very small amounts of the
n-protein that produced in all these
conditions
the serum free light chain test has been
shown to be as if not more sensitive
than immunofixation and a very helpful
aid
finally
serum free light chain tests flc
have been established as a criterion for
stringent complete remission
during therapy
however
it is not
suggested to be used to follow cases of
light chain myeloma at the present the
guidelines recommend using a 24-hour
urine where you measure the
densitometric scan as i just showed you
it's also not used when a patient has an
intact m protein that is followed in the
serum which is about
three-quarters of the cases
so here's an algorithm to detect
multiple myeloma that can be used
if a
clinician suspects that a patient may
have a prostate process that is
consistent with a monoclonal protein
both a serum protein electrophoresis
and a test to
detect monochrome-free light chains
should be performed
the monoclonal three light changes
classically have been immuno fixation on
concentrated urine but these days as i
just showed you the serum free light
chain test can substitute for that
on serum protein electrocurrencies some
individuals automatically some
laboratories automatically perform
immuno fixation others look to see if
there is a suspicious ban
before performing immuno fixation ife
or immunosubtraction iso
so
what does suspicious mean
there's a nice study published in 2010
by dr katzman again at the mayo clinic
and he categorized several
suspicious cases
they looked at 621 cases that had been
followed up at the mayo clinic
his first category was fuzzy band 206
cases fell into that category
of those patients when they performed
immuno fixation ife
over half of them 54
were positive for a monofilament protein
he also categorized some as questionable
fuzzy bands i've actually never been dr
castman down on the difference between
questionable fuzzy band or fuzzy band
but i believe these are the impressions
of the individuals who read the
samples and it probably varies a bit
but clearly there is a difference
because when you look at the 263
patients that had questionable fuzzy
bands
they definitely had monoclonal proteins
in many cases 18
but it wasn't as high a percentage as
when a definite cozy band was present i
will show you a fussy band in just a
second
hypogamma globular anemia is another
important funding they had 85 patients
with hypogamma globulin anemia and 12 of
them had monoclonal proteins at that
time
increased alpha 2 region greater than
1.4 grams per deciliter was found in 48
patients only two of them four percent
had monophonic proteins so you're less
likely to find monoclonal proteins in
the altitude region but you can and i
will also show you that
increased beta region and their criteria
was 1.6 to 1.9 grams per deciliter out
of the 10 cases they had one of them 10
is positive
so
let's take a look at the case
where is the m spike in on these five
cases
well if you look down at them
if you look at the gamma regions in the
beta region the bottom case has a very
large band that's right at the origin
between the beta and the gamma region
and that could be an m protein but when
we did further studies it was fibrinogen
this was a patient that had been
anticoagulated and fibrinogen was not
removed and we're just seeing the
fibrinogen band
but if you look at the c3 bands
on all the different areas that's the
beta 2 band you'll notice that the one
in the second sample indicated by the
arrow is broader it's fuzzier than the
other bands and the fuzziness is because
there's a monochrome protein that is
migrating directly on top of it but also
a little to the left and the right of it
since our
staining here is merely a protein dye
that will stain any protein whether it's
c3 or a monoclonal protein the band
appears fuzzy
but is the proof that it's a monochromal
protein we did an immuno fixation
and it was an iga
lambda m protein
as we showed you earlier iga monoformal
proteins tend to migrate in the beta
region because of that it's important to
have a method that has very crisp
separation of beta 1 and beta 2 bands so
you can pick up on subtleties like this
another study was performed on hypogamma
globular media confirming katzman's
findings this study was performed by
latchman
e anand
and colleagues it was published in
american general clinical pathology
here they looked at 380 patients who had
hypogamma globular media
of them
they found that almost ten percent are
very similar to the twelve percent that
uh cast members and colleagues quoted
uh had and
by immuno fixation a monopoly protein
was present either on serum or urine
here's one of the cases that they show
in their article
there's hypogamma globulin anemia and
began their region and on the same case
when they did immuno fixation
it's stained with kappa
and
lambda as a discrete spike
so what was the importance of detecting
these did these patients have a
clinically relevant
issue and the answer is
yes
the
patients did
more than half of them had a malignant
process
most of the malignant processes
were multiple myeloma but they also had
other cases
of
b cell neoplasms
amyloidosis
and
one individual had a
post-lung transplantation with
peripheral neuropathy
the rest had mgus which needed to be
followed
capillary electrophoresis here we have a
patient that has an unusual finding can
you see where it is
it's
in the output 2 region
it's a very discreet spike this is not
how the altitude region should usually
look so we performed in immuno fixation
shown on the next slide
there's a nice normal g area normal a
normal m normal kappa and normal lambda
there's nothing and there's no spike
seen in the alpha 2 region
so what was that
that was one of the artifacts we talked
about earlier
dr bossett and colleagues reported in
clinical chemistry that one finds
artifacts like this when radio contrast
eyes are present
here i show a
photo from his original paper showing
that hero graphene has a band in the
anode portion of the altitude region
telebrix and omnipeak have
restrictions in the more
cathode land here is our case
and it lined up with omni tape by
checking the patient's chart we found
out this patient in fact was given that
radio contracts died
about having high alpha 2 regions as
suggested by dr caster well here we have
a patient who has two
two suggestive findings the alpha 2
region is high you'll notice it measures
1.9 grams per deciliter and it's flagged
as being high
and the patient also has a low gamma
globulin it's less than the 0.55 that dr
katzman recommended so what is that
bad it looks a little unusual
we performed an even no subtraction and
now you are experts at immunosubtraction
and so you see that that band is
subtracted out by igg
not by a or m
and it is subtracted out by kappa here
is a lighter line rather than the gray
versus blue
and not by lambda so this is an igg
kappa
monophonic democracy
the fact that we know where it's
subtracted out helps us to determine
where we should measure this band and
this way we were able to measure the
band as 1.1 grams per deciliter and
could follow it
what about subtle beta region and
proteins
this study by narayan and colleagues
looked specifically at the beta 1 and
beta 2 regions in over 3 000 consecutive
patients
they found 36 who had elevations in the
beta region beta 1 or beta 2 but there
was no obvious spike so they performed
immuno fixation on those cases
one third of them
had a monoclonal protein detected at
that time
what was the significance of the
monopoly protein two had multiple
myeloma
therefore our laboratory performs an
immuno fixation anytime we see an
elevated beta region where there's not
an obvious beta gamma bridge or big
spike
where there's a distorted fuzzy theta
one or beta two band and you're all not
experts on fuzzy bands
or what is beta one beta two bridging
let's see an example
here's an unexplained increase in the
beta region
it's being labeled as high
and so let's do an immunosubtraction
just looking at the
globulin fractions
you'll notice here
that the iga
and the kappa are subtracting
part of this
beta 1 region spike and you can see the
normal transfer underneath it
lambda is not
subtracted at all neither does g or m
so this is an iga kappa monophonic
protein in the beta region and this is
why that theta region is increased
let's look at another challenging
problem with the newer assays
here's a sample here's a case that was
reported from the mayo clinic 53 year
old woman who had mn multiple myeloma
and she also had some lytic lesions she
had lytic lesions in her right humerus
the biopsy showed over 70
plasma cells all catholic
her urine showed
you pep during protein electric freezers
showed a small kappa spike that measured
32 milligrams in 24 hours
they also did the serum tree light chain
test it's much more convenient than the
urine because you just need a serum
sample you don't have to cook urine for
24 hours
and that showed that the capital was
increased 4.72 milligrams per deciliter
the normal range only goes up to 1.94
while the lambda l was decreased 0.21
the normal load range is 0.57
they decided to follow the patient at
that time by looking at the synonym
three capacitance and it stayed below
five no therapy was given however with
time the patient became anemic and
calcium increased therefore five months
later they decided to repeat the urine
protein electrophoresis and found that
it had increased tenfold
from the original sample
they gave therapy and then they found a
paradoxical increase of the serum free
catholic let's see how this looks
this is the course of this patient's
disease here we have
on the far left is zero days and that's
the initial sample we have the small
amount of free kappa it's under five
milligrams per deciliter and we have the
urine measured and spike and we have
that access in green
and
it wasn't very large either then they
followed the patient with the
serum free capital and it never got
above five
but
then they looked at the urine again on
day 150 and we had a huge spike
therapy was given here and after the
therapy the amount of the free kappa and
the serum prevention test went way up
well over 200 how can it be it's
supposed to go down
that's because there was actually a
large amount present before a therapy
but we couldn't see it because of the
antigen excess effect
so what is that
now let's take a second to review the
typical antibody antigen reaction curve
if you look at precipitation and that's
what we're really looking at with
methylometry
when there's antigen excess
or antibody excess you don't get optimum
precipitation you get optimum
precipitation in the equivalence region
why is that
was because in the zone of equivalence
you form large antibody antigen
complexes where the ratio of antibody to
antigen is about one to one
when you have large amounts of excess
antigen such as seen at the right
the ratio of antigen antibody is huge
maybe 10 to 1 in this case you're only
going to form simple complexes of two
antigens to one antibody since here the
antigens are small molecules such as
kappa they only weigh 25 kilograms that
plus the 160
kilo dalton igg means you're still under
200 kilograms that is not going to form
a particle that will be detected by
nepalometry and so it will appear as
though there is very little presence
when a huge amount is present
why does that happen with this assay
well part of it is because you're
looking at relatively small antigens but
also remember i showed you earlier there
were only a few epitopes only the
cloaked epitopes are looked at with this
technique
because of that
i believe we have a smaller equivalence
region and in order to
find out the correct
value one has to perform many different
dilutions to see
uh antibody antigen interaction at a
range of antigen concentrations
this was described on the covenant
columns they called it an antigen excess
high dose hook effect
and they recommended doing a depth check
looking at the serum free y chain assays
and diluting ones that had changed by
more than 300 milligrams per liter
between samples
for patients that have a previous
history of a
high dose hook effect if there is the
technical monotone protein by serum
protein or decreases spe and immuno
fixation
but a normal
ratio are of the serum three like chains
flc
you should also perform dilution studies
the cotton and colleagues also
recommended comparing the results to the
results of the intact and protein spike
these
findings were taken very seriously by
the company that produces the serum free
light chain test and they produced this
package insert
that provides many suggestions from the
mccutten study
okay so this is the algorithm i
originally showed you
doing serum protein electrocreases and
serum tree line chain test and this has
been the standard for some time
however
there is a new test on uh that could be
of some interest it's called the heavy
light chain test
what is that
let's take a look at the immunoglobulin
molecule the immunoglobulin molecule
consists of two identical heavy chains
gamma alpha mu delta or epsilon
and they're attached by disulfide bonds
to
two identical like chains
kappa or lambda and we showed you that
there were some determinants that were
unique to the light chains that are
hidden on the interior of the molecule
well when you combine the light chains
to the heavy chains that also creates
unique determinants between
the
light chain and the heavy chain
bradwell and colleagues got together
again and created a very unique product
they found that they could create
antibodies that would identify
specifically igg kappa molecules versus
igg
lambda molecules and iga
kappa molecules versus iga lambda etc
here's a table from their paper showing
how they develop their 95 percent
confidence interval they did studies on
blood donors and as you can see they
develop a normal range for igg kappa iga
kappa ig m kappa etc
and they also look at the ratios because
just as with the monofilament free light
chains the ratios are of key importance
here showing the ranges for g kappa
g lambda
a kappa a lambda
m kappa and n lambda
so how those work in practice okay
here's another figure from their paper
again we're grabbing the igg
kappa versus igg lambda
and you see that as with the serum 3
light chain test there is a normal range
that i have in the blue rectangular
diagonal bracket and you see
ones that have excess g kappa or xsg
lambda myeloma patients are on the top
and the bottom of it same is true for
igm
and also for iga
now iga is an interesting molecule
because as we said earlier it tends to
migrate
in the beta region and it can be
obscured by proteins that migrate in
that region so if we look at
bottom left
chart c
let's look at these particular five
cases they show them in d and e which
i'm going to
enlarge on this next slide
okay
these are five cases that they pointed
out that they thought that the iga
capital lambda ratio could help you and
in fact it is helpful
underneath the table i've given you
their normal reference range of
0.58 to 2.52
with the nhs the normal human serum
you can see the ratio
i've outlined in red is correct it's
1.49 above you see the gel electric
freezes but one thing i'd like you to
note about this gel electrophoresis
it is a poor quality in terms of
separation of the beta 1 and the beta 2
bands
i prefer a crisp separation because it
makes it easier for me to see the bands
let's take a look at the five cases that
they show
case number one
i see a little band there maybe there's
something in the cabinet region but
that's all i can see they describe it as
a weak
gamma band
and it does have a very abnormal ratio
and it is a weak band but there's also
something else about that case compare
the gamma region to the normal human
serum
the normal human serum gamma region
looks darker
that's because there's normal amount of
gamma globulin they don't tell us the
total amount of gamma globulin in these
cases but i would submit that all of
these cases look like they're hypogamma
globulin
so these are cases that by the uh
island study or by catchment study i
would want to do an immuno fixation on
anyway
but there's that then
let's look at case two there's a very
definite band here they say that there
are beta and gamma bands there and a
very abnormal
capital n ratio of 44.4 certainly
consistent and helpful
case 3 they described as alpha 2 band i
have trouble seeing that the alpha 2
region looks a little darker but i
actually thought that there may be a
band here
and that one had a
lower ratio of
13.5 on the other two cases but still
way out of the normal range
and here's another band in that sample
case four is described as having a weak
beta region band and i think they're
talking about this little area
slightly um cathode to the major beta
bands but again the beta bands are not
well resolved in this and it's harder to
see
this gave a low ratio 0.17
indicating it was a likely lambda
process
and uh the normal range only goes down
to 0.58 so again helpful but very
hypogenic probability example as well
case number five they've saved multiple
bands and i certainly agree i can see at
least two
and uh the range once again is low but
pretty darn close to the 0.58
so
heavy chain light chain analysis i think
is a very interesting area there have
been some recent studies that
have shown that it may also be a very
important
you have an important use in stratifying
risk for
mgus cases but a lot of work needs to be
done in other labs to confirm this
information it is intriguing
what are my conclusions from these
studies
first
when you're screening for multi for
monoclonal proteins serum protein
electric freezes with a method that
shows good resolution is important
and also there should be a method that
can detect
free light chains you can use the
classic urine free urinal fixation or
serum free light chain test the catspin
study clearly shows it's at least as
effective
be aware of the high dose hook effect
with serum free light chain test is a
great test but you do have to be aware
of this
immunosubtraction not only can be useful
to classify uh m protein type
but it is also useful to aiding in the
measurement of the monoclonal protein
itself
finally the heavy light chain test is a
very exciting
promising new technique and i suspect
there'll be some really interesting
studies uh that
one will see in the future
okay i have
one question it says in terms
of
mechanism
what causes a free life chain to be
generated
uh is it an aberrant production of
antibodies ah it's an excellent question
well
all plasma cells you can view plasma
cells as inefficient factories they
produce
the light chains and heavy chains
separately but they also produce excess
amounts of the free light chains so not
all the free light chains are bound to
heavy chains those light chains are
excreted into the serum so even in
normal people we will have three light
chains being excreted into the serum i
don't know why they're inefficient in
this way and maybe somebody else
on the line can answer that question but
so it is a normal process that the free
life chains
the plasma cells will produce excess of
free light chains
these
if you have a monotonal democracy now
you have clones producing the same heavy
and light chain but they also will
produce excess amounts of the free light
chain type
and that can be detected in the serum
by the serum free light chain test
because they're small molecules 25
kilodaltons for the kappa monomers or 50
kilovolts approximately for the the
dimers
of lambda
they will pass into the euro and you can
detect them there by urine immune
fixation
but the urine
reabsorbs
some of those molecules across the
tubules and so the serum immuno fixation
test the achievement of the serum free
light chain test is actually a little
more sensitive than the urine immuno
fixation test because of that
reabsorption you don't get to see all
the live chains in the urine
i hope that answers the question i don't
seem to have any other questions so i
hope you enjoyed this talk hope it is
useful to you you are welcome to email
me at the university of michigan you've
got my name and
on the cover slide and i'd be glad to
answer any other questions you may have
so thanks very much for attending today